so first example you were asked to bring
handouts of a document to the meeting
but you actually forgot to print out the
documents in time next you created an
excellent analysis with some client data
with some information that you received
and then you shared some results from
that analysis with a client or with
colleagues and then at some point you
find out that some formulas in the model
were wrong that your model had a problem
and likely the data that you shared is
now inaccurate or maybe you asked the
question in a meeting and then you share
the wrong information because you
misremembered it along these lines of
course many other things can go wrong as
well maybe you missed the deadline for a
piece of work that you needed to submit
or you actually have some spelling or
grammar mistakes in any of your
documents